- Any kind of art discipline,
I think the possibilities are endless.
I think this life is so
brief and we spend it,
sometimes, imposing over
ourselves, so many limitations.
Never underestimate a five
foot three Columbian girl.
- Shakira is a firecracker.
- Whee.
- She's a Columbian singer, songwriter,
dancer, and record producer.
Her song "Hips Don't Lie" is one of the
best selling singles of the 21st century.
She has a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame
and is one of the best selling
Latin artists of all time.
She's Shakira, and here's my take on
her top ten rules for success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
Also guys, as you're watching
if you hear something that really
resonates with you, please leave it
down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
Also, when you write it
down, it's much more likely
to lock in for yourself as well, enjoy.
(wind gust)
(lively music)
- I grew up in Columbia.
And Columbia, it's a developing country
where a lot of people don't have access
to the most basic needs
and where education is
considered a luxury,
unfortunately, because we all know that
education is a birthright.
I just grew up frustrated seeing
how many people weren't able to
realize their own dreams, you know.
When I was eight years old,
my dad underwent an economic
crisis, a financial crisis,
he lost his business, and we struggled,
economically, for many years.
We lost our car,
we lost our furniture, (laughs)
and I remember vividly the day I walked in
my house and all the furniture was gone
because my dad had to pay his debts.
And it was quite, well, shocking for me.
I was seven, eight years old,
and when I saw this
I was so frustrated.
I was so upset with my parents cause
I couldn't understand
how they did so poorly
in business, you know?
I'm like "Why, why?" I couldn't get it.
My dad and my mom took me to the park
where they showed me other kids,
my age, sniffing glue.
They were orphans.
They had no one to watch after them.
They were barefoot and they were abandoned
to their own luck.
And it, probably, left such an impression
in my impressionable mind, at that age,
that I remember that day.
I remember that I made myself a promise.
I said to myself Shakira,
you have to succeed,
because you have to
ride in a car again one day, (laughs)
you have to get your own car someday.
I wanted to vindicate my parents,
socially and economically,
and I also wanted
to someday do something for those kids
who I saw that day in the park.
So, as soon as I had my
first big success with
Pies Descalzos, which was my third album,
I decided to establish my own foundation
and do my own contribution to the change.
Even if it was going to be a small one.
But I wanted to be active.
And that's how it all started.
Going through my own financial struggle
and the struggle of my family
and understanding that the one thing
that I never lacked was care, protection
and an education.
And that's, probably, what
made me thrive in life.
I didn't know exactly how this
album was going to turn out.
You can never predict
those kind of things.
There's nothing scarier than standing
in front of a white canvas.
You never know if you're going to be able
to provide something new
to those who expect it.
But in any kind of art discipline,
I think the possibilities are endless.
That's something that I
always learn the hard way,
with every album, because I suffer
through the process sometimes.
I'm like, oh my God, I'm never going to do
anything that I like.
Until boom, it appears, magically.
I guess, if you keep rubbing the lamp
the genies of the lamp has
got to show up at sometime.
This has been my experience
throughout the years.
With every album, I get
really, really nervous
the first months in the studio.
Searching,
exploring,
trying things that sometimes don't work,
until you find the magic,
or the magic finds you
while you're working. (laughs)
- So when you meet new
talent, emerging talent
and you're mentoring them,
what if you don't have a confidence
that they have the level of talent
required to achieve greatness?
How do you counsel them?
What do you say to make
them feel confident
to not rob them of that
moment but also steer them
in the right direction?
I mean, you can't say,
really, "You're a zero."
(laughter)
- By talking to them,
understanding what their concerns are,
what sort of self-image they have,
and trying to show them
their strengths, too.
If they have some kind of weakness,
we'll try to not focus
on those weaknesses.
I think in entertainment
industry that's what works.
You know your strengths, you milk em.
You know your weaknesses, you try not
to focus on them so much,
so the audience doesn't
focus on them as much.
I'm more worried now about being true
to myself and being honest.
Maybe ten years ago,
I would have not done a
video like, "She Wolf"
but now, it's something I feel like doing.
So why am I going to deprive myself
or deny myself the possibility
of expressing the way I feel?
I want to express myself freely.
I don't want to be in
a golden cage anymore.
I don't want to be put behind bars.
I think this life is so brief
and we spend it, sometimes,
imposing over ourselves,
so many limitations and obstacles
that don't allow us to
grow as we would like to.
And yes, I feel like a woman
and this time around I
wanted to show my legs.
I never showed my legs
for 20 years. (laughs)
I always did all my
performances with long pants
believe it or not.
I never showed my legs, and one day
I looked and them and I
said "Hey, they're not bad."
"They're kind of short but
they take me to places."
"I think it's now or never." (laughs)
It's about time to really embrace
my individuality and my freedom
as a woman, as a person.
That's a message that I
encourage to other women.
That doesn't mean, necessarily,
letting yourself be objectified.
Because that means satisfying
the desires of other people.
I say, satisfy your own desires,
and live your life to the
fullest, because it's short.
- All these awards, after
winning so many Grammys
and the rest of it, what sort of motivates
you to create new things, new music?
(sighs)
- You know, I shouldn't be this motivated
because after so many years I should be
a little bit more calm about everything.
But I love what I do and I'm always
putting myself in front of new challenges
and I guess I'm still hungry.
How am I going to discover the talent
that my son has?
How am I going to encourage him
to follow his own dreams?
It's a conundrum, and it's a challenge
for every parent out there, I think.
But if it weren't because of my mom,
I think that I would have never made it,
Cause she realized that I was talented,
but not only that.
She supported me, she believed in me
and she went ahead and help me,
help me build my confidence,
my own confidence.
Confidence in myself which is a vital
tool that you need in order
to survive any kind of job.
- Why do you think it all
came together for you?
- Why?
A lot of hard work, a
lot of determination.
I consider myself a laborer of what I do.
An artisan, and I think I've been
building my career, putting
a brick over a brick
under the sun, with sweat and hard work.
That's the way I've done it.
I haven't given up, not one moment.
There must be something very abnormal
about this, because
it's been so many years
doing this and I still care so much.
I don't think that's normal.
But with every project I feel
that I haven't accomplished anything.
That I feel that I'm starting from zero,
and I care tremendously.
In a way that, sometimes, it surprises me.
- So you feel like you have to
- It's still there.
prove yourself over and over again.
- Yes. I think that I have to be,
that I have to embrace new
challenges and those challenges
make me grow, and growing
is the only way to go.
The only way I conceive life.
So, yeah, that's the way I see it.
I think that we all come to
this world with a star, with a talent,
and with a gift.
And then, later, dreams are born.
And no one, absolutely no one
has the authority to stop those dreams.
When I was seven years old,
I came to Los Angeles for the first time
and I passed by the Walk of Fame
with my mother and a friend
of hers who's, actually,
here with us today, (laughs)
(crowd cheers)
and I remember that my mom
told me, "Shaki, one day you're
"going to have your name on this place."
(cheering)
If someone would have
overheard this conversation
they would have thought
that my mom was delirious.
But she was not, and here we are.
so I want to say to all of you
to dream as big as you can,
because in this country
everything is possible.
- You sound so passionate about so many
diverse pieces of your life,
that the big question is
how do you juggle all that?
How do you make all of that
happen and successfully?
From your music career, to being a mom,
to being a life partner, like all of that
is so hard to juggle.
How do you do it?
What's the secret behind that?
- I don't know how I'm going
to keep doing it. (laughs)
That's a good question,
because with a baby
things tend to change a lot.
But I have a great team,
people who understand me very
well, who understand my cause,
my commitments and who support em
and make my life easier.
So it is very important
to be well surrounded.
- You're perfect, Shakira. You're perfect.
(crowd cheers)
- She is the perfect woman.
But you're talking about winning
this show right now.
- C'mon!
- Don't be mean!
- Uh oh!
(crowd cheers)
- Dammit.
(laughs)
There is nothing worse than being scolded
by Shakira when she goes from zero to 100
and you're not going to get a word in.
- I'm speaking to you
- Hey, you know what--
from the bottom of my heart.
- And you know what--
how things are going to
get on this competition.
- And with the--
- Sorry.
(crowd laughs)
- Baa.
- You never get into an argument
with a Latin woman.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You don't mess with Shakira.
Don't debate with her.
- I'll take that--
- Hold on, time out, time out.
- Are you sure?
- Time out.
It's a complicated decision.
- While she's talking, shut up.
- I just want to say something.
- Aba-a.
- You guys, you are a completely
different animal, you know?
(crowd laughs)
These are alpha dogs.
Perros alfa.
(laughter)
Never underestimate a five
foot three Colombian girl.
- Shakira is a firecracker.
- Waa.
- She's very spicy.
- You're coming to my team,
so let's make this quick.
- Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Not without my permission first.
- Here's what I do when Shakira starts
getting feisty, I do this.
(lively music)
- I, Shakira Mebarak,
born in Barranquilla, Columbia,
- I promise you, I, Adam Levine
from Los Angeles, California.
(laughter)
- Hey, Adam.
You know, he has this tattoo that says
"Wrong coach for you."
(laughter)
- Damn. The claws are out.
(cat screech)
- It's hard.
It's hard to be right all the time.
Ah, ah, no, no, no.
- That's, that's not, but that--
- Are you going to take that?
- Hey.
(crowd laughs)
Hey, my hips don't lie.
I don't lie either.
- Tell him Shakira, tell him.
(laughter)
- Personally, I think it's adorable.
I actually love that side of her.
- It doesn't matter what
Shakira says, it's always right.
- Thank you.
(crowd cheers)
- Thank you guys so much for watching
I made this video because
Khalid Azzam asked me to.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what did Shakira say
that had the biggest impact on you?
What clip was your
favorite from these ten?
And also, what are you
going to immediately
take from this video and apply somehow
to your life or to your business?
Leave it down in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a quick shout out
to Damn Purvis. Damn, thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book
"Your One Word", it
really, really, really,
really means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys so much for watching
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
(wind whips)
- To be able to succeed in America
was very important.
It represented to me a
reaffirmation, as an artist.
He should keep it, just
have notes, you know?
Let's try it.
Performing at the VMAs means freedom.
It means that you really have your chance
to do whatever you want up on stage.
And it means being among
the most successful artists.
It's too long still.
(singing)
If I could just conquer
my own insecurities
and conquer other hearts, too,
it would demonstrate that my music
was powerful enough to transcend
so many barriers.
Da, da, da, da, da, da, boom.
- Ga, ga, ga, ga, ga, ga, boom.
- Yeah. There.
(singing and clapping)
You do one, then you wait.
- [Male Voice] No, no, that's it.
- And then you. (laughs)
You know, I'm so excited
with what we have now,
that I would like the
VMAs to happen tonight.
I would be ready.
♫ I'm falling apart in your hands again
I am the conqueror. (laughs)